[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida a esta emisión especial de
aquí a américa hoy le daremos una mirada
profunda a los atentados terroristas del
11 de septiembre de 2001 en eeuu
para hacer lo vamos a recordar minuto a
minuto lo que sucedió ese día hace 20
años con los informes preparados desde
nuestra redacción en bogotá y con el
testimonio de sobrevivientes que se
transformaron en héroes y en heroínas
y de la mano de nuestros corresponsales
en nueva york y en washington
revisaremos qué significaban las zonas
atacadas para los estadounidenses y cómo
se transformaron y junto con expertos le
explicaremos sobre la guerra contra el
terrorismo iniciada tras este atentado y
sus consecuencias acompáñenme en esta
emisión especial para entender por qué
el 11-s cambió al mundo para siempre
el 11 de septiembre de 2001 19 hombres
vinculados a al qaeda secuestraron 4
aviones comerciales para dirigirse a
varios destinos de la costa este de eeuu
fueron cuatro atentados coordinados en
poco más de una hora durante la cual la
unión americana veía llamas y humo en
emblemáticos edificios en nueva york' en
arlington virginia y en un campo alguna
vez desconocido de pensilvania el primer
avión el vuelo 11 de american airlines
fue deliberadamente chocado a las 8 y 46
de la mañana contra la torre norte del
world trade center en manhattan era un
boeing 767 en el que viajaban 92
personas entre ellos los cinco
secuestradores
mientras el mundo veía por televisión
como la primera potencia era atacada el
vuelo 175 de united airlines fue
estrellado a las nueve y tres de la
mañana contra la torre sur también en la
gran manzana se trataba igual de un
boeing 767 en el que viajaban 65
personas también 5 secuestradores
a los nueve y treinta y siete el vuelo
77 de american airlines golpeó el
pentágono la sede del departamento de
defensa en virginia en el iván 64
personas incluidos los cinco
secuestradores era un boeing 757
y a las 10 y 3 minutos el vuelo 93 de
united airlines se estrelló en un campo
cerca de shanksville pensilvania con 44
personas a bordo cuatro de ellos
yihadistas también era un buen 75 72
1996 personas de múltiples
nacionalidades murieron y seis mil más
resultaron heridas en estos ataques
terroristas orquestados por el jefe de
al qaeda osama bin laden
andrés doncel nos recapitula como se
vivió ese día en el siguiente informe
martes 11 de septiembre de 2001
es un día soleado en nueva york' la
ciudad se prepara para las elecciones
primarias del partido republicano y del
demócrata para la alcaldía
[Música]
a las 8 46 de la mañana los informativos
del mundo comienzan a reportar sobre un
accidente en la torre norte del world
trade center la confusión es total los
reportes indican que un pequeño avión
volando bajo un helicóptero se chocó con
el edificio
17 minutos después a las 9 de la mañana
con tres minutos y con todas las cámaras
enfocadas en nueva york' el mundo mira
atónito como un boing 757 un vuelo
comercial de united airlines se estrella
contra la torre sur
[Música]
ahora no había dudas el país más
poderoso del mundo estaba bajo ataque
907 sarasota florida el presidente
george bush se encuentra reunido con
unos niños de una escuela primaria
cuando el jefe de personal le avisa que
embistieron la segunda torre
simultáneamente la administración
federal de aviación ordena la
prohibición de despegue de todos los
aviones que se dirigen o sobrevuelan el
espacio aéreo de nueva york'
werner son traidores
resources desarrollaron
en qué dirección
león
entre los fox lo que merece
en el firmamento
m
[Aplausos]
[Música]
virginia 937
se reporta una explosión en el corazón
de la defensa estadounidense otro avión
se estrella contra el pentágono
hola amigos win to work
de bueno iba a trabajar de repente
escuchó un gran ruido y simplemente
salir de inmediato del auto luego vimos
que el avión se acercaba y rodeaba está
área y el ala subía y bajaba de esta
manera luego fue sólo unos segundos y se
estrelló de inmediato
[Música]
945 o se prohíbe el despegue de
cualquier aeronave en eeuu y se ordena
del aterrizaje inmediato de todos los
vuelos nacionales por primera vez en la
historia del país el congreso y el ala
oeste de la casa blanca' son evacuados
tras los primeros impactos y con la
certeza de otro secuestro la fuerza
aérea comienza a buscar desesperadamente
el vuelo 93 de united airlines que
partió del aeropuerto internacional de
newark hacia san francisco
[Música]
1 959 la segunda torre en ser impactada
es la primera en caer uno de los iconos
del poder estadounidense es derrumbado
[Música]
10 03 shanksville pensilvania
a unos 450 km de la gran manzana el
vuelo 93 de united airlines cae en medio
del campo fracasando en su intento de
impactar la casa blanca o el capitolio
10 28
cae la torre norte una hora 41 minutos
después del impacto del avión
2030 washington dice tras varias horas
de silencio y confusión el presidente
bush habla nuevamente pero esta vez en
un discurso televisado en el que asegura
que eeuu no hará distinciones entre los
que cometen los actos terroristas y los
que les protegen o cobijan
el singular
vivo de especular
espolí
pero posee más
en el cual a nivel de negro
vettel
alcanzó y strong
great nation
y
puede que no te defendés en américa
en este sentido
merkel estado de ánimo en el mismo foro
en world el sol de stein
en just world
sanger en el hangar la semana
un día que muchos sin importar la edad
tenemos en la memoria entre las miles de
historias de sobrevivientes está la de
william rodríguez
él era el conserje de la torre norte del
world trade center actualmente es el
presidente del grupo de víctimas
hispanas del 11 de septiembre william
cuéntanos cómo empezó ese día para usted
el 11 de septiembre es un día precioso
es un día claro es un día de elecciones
en la ciudad de nueva york yo me levanto
tarde y digo no voy a trabajar y ahí yo
llamo a mi supervisor llamado anthony
saltalamacchia y le digo anthony pone un
día de enfermedad y él me dice no estás
loco tienes que venir a trabajar y era
que si yo no iba a trabajar nadie quería
hacer mi trabajo porque yo limpiaba 110
pisos de escaleras diariamente una labor
casi sobrehumana porque era un trabajo
que se supone que si se hiciese por tres
personas y lo hacía solamente yo
entonces cuando yo veo que él está así
como medio inseguro le dijo que está la
oportunidad de negociar y le digo si tú
me pones la tarjeta como que llegué a
las 8 de la mañana yo voy a trabajar sí
no iniciá no te preocupes llega a ellos
definimos la tarjeta llegó el world
trade center llegó a las ocho y media me
voy directamente al sótano de la torre
número uno y finalmente pueda trabajar
entonces cuéntenos dónde estaba
exactamente cuando escuchó la primera
explosión voy a las ocho y media
directamente al sótano de la torre
número 1 el world trade center tenía 6
sus niveles de sótano y mientras estoy
hablando con el supervisor habían 15
trabajadores nuevos que se usaban como
reemplazo de vacaciones gente que se iba
de vacaciones y traían reemplazos
temporeros no conocían el edificio y
mientras estoy hablando con el
supervisor a las 8 y 46 se oye
una explosión tan fuerte y tan poderosa
que nos levanta en el aire el techo en
falso se derrumba encima de nosotros los
rociadores contra incendios se activan
las paredes se relajan en la máquina de
fax se cae en el piso pero hay una
gritería total porque estamos en un
sótano y no tenemos ventanas no sabemos
qué pasó y lo primero que yo pienso es
que un generador de energía eléctrica ha
reventado en el cuarto de mecánica que
se encontraba en el sótano número 2
exactamente de nosotros y como nos
levantó en el aire cuando yo lo voy a
verbalizar de 6 a 7 segundos después se
oye en la parte de arriba del edificios
bien fuerte el edificio se oye como que
se está desgarrando y es por la
oscilación el edificio fue diseñado para
auxiliar de lado a lado por el factor
viento pero esta vez fue tan duro que se
oía el crujir se oía de las paredes y al
yo escuchar eso en que el supervisor
empieza a gritarme es una bomba es una
bomba y nuevamente no tenemos ventanas
no sabemos lo que está ocurriendo y yo
digo tenemos que organizarnos tenemos
que hacer algo y cuando estoy diciendo
eso que miro en el pasillo que llevaba
directamente a mi oficina del área de
central del sótano número uno vieron
hombres corriendo con la mano extendida
los dos brazos diciendo explosión
explosión explosión y lo que parecía ser
tela cubriéndolo en la punta de los
dedos cuando se acerca nos damos cuenta
y empezamos a gritar en puro horror que
no era tela lo que le colgaba era la
piel se le había arrancado debajo de las
axilas de los dos brazos y se le había
pelado como si cuando tú te quitas un
guante así le estaba colgando en la
punta de los dedos y aquello fue total
total horror y yo le empiezo a gritar
qué pasó qué pasó y elvira la cara y
cuando hubiera la cara le colgaban
pedazos de su cara es un señor de la
raza negra llamado felipe da mitad al
patio no conocía y le digo no te muevas
porque le tenía todo estaba empapado en
sangre aquella camisa roja que tenía era
con quitarme empapado en sangre y nadie
lo quería tocar nadie porque en el 2001
bien teníamos aquella campaña contra el
sida de no tocar a nadie con sangre y
entonces está todo organizado entonces
yo me meto en la oficina como una caja
de toallas y comienzo a brindarlo y le
digo no te muevas voy a llamar a la
unidad de servicios médicos que se
encontraba en la torre sur la torre
sobre la torre norte conectaban por el
sótano y ello era muy eficiente para
estos casos de emergencia y cuando tomó
el teléfono dentro de la oficina
una explosión bien fuerte el piso
empieza a temblar y nos da la sensación
de que un terremoto todo el mundo se
mete debajo de los marcos de las puertas
de la oficina pensando de que es un
terremoto y ahí empiezo yo a gritar
tenemos que salir tenemos que salir
nadie quería salir nadie se atrevía a
salir entonces yo me pongo el señor
quemado con la ayuda de otro trabajador
en el hombro porque nadie lo quería
tocar y entonces comienzo a liderar este
grupo de trabajadores nuevo al
supervisor y al señor quemado
por el área de carga y descarga del
edificio ahí hay una cuesta una rampa
subimos la rampa y cuál llegará afuera
vemos una ambulancia para la ambulancia
meto al señor y ahí oigo por primera vez
un avión impactó la torre un avión
impactó la torre y era el radio la
transmisión de radio que tenía el hombre
de seguridad encargado de permitir que
camiones entrar con envíos al edificio
por esa rampa y cuando miro en la calle
todo el mundo está mirando con la boca
abierta
sorprendido y cuando yo me vino a ver
qué era lo que miraban ahí yo digo dios
mío qué es esto he visto el agujero por
donde entró del avión he visto el fuego
he visto el humo pero el humo era tan
denso que cubría la torre norte y
escombros cayendo pero desde el punto de
vista que yo tenía no podía discernir
bien que lo que yo te estaba viendo que
estaba cayendo no eran escombrera que la
gente se estaba tirando y yo no podía
saber eso en ese momento y cuando no ve
ahora antena
yo digo dios mío la gente de windows la
gente de windows me refería a la gente
de windows of the world el restaurant
que se encontraba en el ciento 607 de la
torre norte y cuando yo digo eso tenemos
que volver tenemos que volver me doy
cuenta en ese momento que estoy vivo de
milagro porque si yo llegas a llegar a
las 8 de la mañana como se supone que
llegar a todos los días me toma el avión
allá arriba porque yo comenzaba
limpiando desde el último piso hacia
abajo y siempre iba a windows of the
world porque me daban el desayuno gratis
es el testimonio de william rodríguez
que nos cuenta los momentos de angustia
y confusión que se vivieron en el world
trade center
william usted tenía una llave maestra
o 300 que tenía cinco llave maestra
las personas con las otras cuatro eran
los entrenados los jefes de mi jefe y la
quinta la isabela tenía yo y ellos se
fueron corriendo y yo tenía en ese
momento el artículo de salvación y le
dijo si tengo la llave me dice vamos
llegamos al vestíbulo de la torre norte
el lobby número 1 el nuevo lo único que
teníamos y ahí están la imagen más
increíble mis héroes los bomberos de la
ciudad de nueva york
con todo ese equipo
ahí están los héroes de la ciudad de
nueva york con todo ese equipo tenían
casi 40 kilos en sus espaldas de
máquinas y de cosas entonces yo vi que
como ellos trataban de
maniobrar y el policía le dice no
esperen por el ascenso están esperando
por el ascensor central llamado el
elevador 50 ja quien le dice el elevador
cuando entró el avión rompió los cables
y había gente adentro y cayó y cesc
síganlo a él conoce muy bien el edificio
y tiene la llave maestra y esa unidad de
héroe me sigue piso por piso mientras yo
comienzo a abrir puertas y sacar gente
abrir puertas y sacar gente empiezo a
hacer mi mi proceso de evacuación entre
los dos bomberos hacen su trabajo
william y cuéntanos cómo pasa uno de
tener esa respuesta de convertirse en
héroe cuando el instinto le diría a uno
hay que salir a correr
muchas preguntas porque regresaba
constantemente al edificio en un momento
tan trágico y era porque primero hubo
una disociación personal yo no estaba
pensando en mí en ningún momento y
estaba pensando en mis amigos mis amigos
mis amigos la compasión humana en ese
momento tomo poder de mi personalidad
100% yo estaba tan desesperado en llegar
y ayudar que jamás pensé en que algo me
iba a pasar era como que yo no estaba
presente y la necesidad de otros fue lo
que tomo prioridad en ese momento
y cuáles son las secuelas que le quedan
a usted de este día porque a pesar de
que es un héroe también es una víctima
un sobreviviente la secuela más
importante porque digo importante no de
forma negativa es darme cuenta de que
mira yo lo tuve yo no tuve pesadillas
como mucha gente la tuvo simplemente
porque yo me di a la labor de hacer algo
que los demás no estaban haciendo yo
tenía un cargo de conciencia
yo no tenía algo por que sentirme mal
porque yo me sacrifiqué 100% por eso yo
no tuve esas pesadillas si tuve de vez
en cuando un uno que otro sueño malo
pero lo que me afectaba y te lo digo con
toda la sinceridad era que cada vez que
me metía dentro de un ascensor en un
edificio para hacer una presentación una
entrevista o algo yo vi a los gritos de
la gente quemándose porque cuando yo
subía las escaleras para sacar personas
la gente dentro de los ascensores y
nadie habla de eso se estaban quemando y
entonces yo recuerdo mirar a los
bomberos y me hacían así
como que no podían hacer nada y eso a mí
me afectó tanto que yo prefería tomar
las escaleras de cualquier edificio que
iba a hacer algo para evitar meterme en
un ascensor otra secuela es que yo
desarrollé ambas lo pues yo no tenía un
hombre que limpiaba 110 pisos de
escaleras imagínense yo he tenido las
piernas de acero de desarrollo alma por
inhalar el polvo tóxico y desarrollo cif
y es que en inglés en español quiere
decir el síndrome de fatiga crónica
desarrolló un síndrome de que a veces
estoy tres y cuatro días sin dormir pero
lo uso proactivamente aprendido usarlo
proactivamente
es el desgarrador testimonio de william
rodríguez un sobreviviente y un héroe
del 11 de septiembre gracias por
habernos acompañado
y es que 20 años después de estos
ataques terroristas el recuerdo de ese
atentado que tomó por sorpresa al
corazón de eeuu se mantiene vigente el
world trade center era un icono de la
unión americana vamos allá con nuestra
corresponsal en nueva york' mamen sala
quien recorrió la que fue declarada como
'zona cero' y nos explica qué
significaban las torres gemelas para la
gran manzana y para eeuu
el world trade center que en español se
traduce como centro mundial del comercio
era un conglomerado de edificios
financieros que se encontraban aquí en
el bajo manhattan y ocupaba un espacio
de 1.200.000 metros cuadrados la mayoría
de las oficinas se encontraban en las
famosas torres gemelas que eran desde
luego la insignia más representativa de
esta zona y se encontraban justo detrás
de nosotros
pero sin duda el cambio más
significativo es el que dejó el derrumbe
de las dos torres gemelas que cambió
completamente el skyline de nueva york-
ese vacío se cubrió con dos fuentes
enormes como esta que están viendo donde
el agua ocurre las 24 horas del día
siete días a la semana como símbolo de
vida los nombres de las casi 3.000
personas que fallecieron aquel 11 de
septiembre del 2001 están inscritos aquí
y sus cumpleaños se recuerdan con flores
como esta
[Música]
justo entre las dos piscinas están
viendo detrás de mí el museo en homenaje
a las víctimas de aquel 11 de septiembre
lo inauguró el ex presidente barack
obama 13 años después de los atentados y
caminar por él no es nada fácil porque
recogen más de 10.000 objetos que se
encontraron entre los escombros hace 20
años
dentro de este museo podemos encontrar
fotografías videos pertenencias de las
víctimas e incluso algún fragmento de
las torres gemelas objetos que se
recogieron aquel día y que nos recuerdan
que esta ciudad no sólo cambió
físicamente sino también su manera de
entender la seguridad desde ese día los
principales lugares públicos y más
concurridos de esta ciudad se protegen
con bolardos como estos además la
policía su presencia en las calles se ha
redoblado porque desde aquel 11 de
septiembre del 2001 los estadounidenses
se dieron cuenta por primera vez que
también eran vulnerables
[Música]
aquel 11 de septiembre del 2001 el mundo
entero cambió pero sobre todo este país
la vida la política la sociedad y la
manera de relacionarse entre ellos nunca
volvieron a ser la misma y todo ello se
ve reflejado también en cambios físicos
en el urbanismo de la ciudad de nueva
york como este parque que se construyó
por ejemplo después de los atentados o
la iglesia ortodoxa que están viendo
detrás de mí y que si no se sigue
retrasando estará terminada para abril
del 2022 producto del arquitecto
santiago calatrava y por la que cada año
pasan más de 7 millones de turistas
el derrumbe de las torres gemelas
provocó una enorme nube de polvo que se
extendió por todo nueva york y cientos
de miles de toneladas de escombros en
esta zona que se tardaron al menos un
año en limpiar cientos de inmigrantes
muchos de ellos indocumentados
participaron en estas labores de
limpieza como ruby el área que hoy está
aquí con nosotros buenas tardes buenas
tardes
bueno yo estoy aquí cuando cuando estoy
limpiando la zona cero estaba sin
documentos gracias ya los tengo para
vídeo de 8 meses
en limpiar esta zona limpia de esta zona
y vuelven difícil porque fue difícil
porque había mucha destrucción
muchos sentimientos encontrados porque
me ponía a pensar en lo que estaba
sufriendo las familias de todas las
personas que me llegaron acá
entonces el software identifica como
trabajo en qué condiciones de sueldo y
de seguridad
no tuvimos mucha seguridad nos dieron
una mascarilla de papel la cual lo
utilizamos todo el día y la misma la
misma
fuera del área y después de las 40 horas
a 12 dólares
debido a esa poca seguridad usted a día
de hoy tiene varias enfermedades
provocadas por esa nube tóxica y esos
materiales cancerígenos
yo tengo problemas con los pulmones
tengo problemas con mi hígado tengo
problemas con el estómago crónico tengo
seguro de estrés postraumático
me da muchas muchas depresiones tengo
muchos problemas de toro en todo mi
cuerpo tengo también
fibromalgia
a consecuencia de todo lo que trabajamos
acá de los de los tóxicos cuántas
pastillas toma usted de entre 15 a 18
pastillas diarias depende de cómo me
sienta
enferma me tomen por finalmente
pastillas y con todo esto se arrepiente
o se ha arrepentido en algún momento de
haber venido aquí a ayudar no no me
arrepiento porque yo sentía la necesidad
estar acá ayudando
no me arrepiento
[Música]
en otro punto de eeuu que también fue
blanco del ataque del 11 de septiembre
fue el pentágono el tercer avión
secuestrado fue chocado contra el ala
oeste de la fachada de la sede del
departamento de defensa estadounidense
125 personas que estaban en el edificio
perdieron la vida nuestro corresponsal
cristóbal vázquez nos muestra la zona
el tercer avión secuestrado fue el vuelo
77 de american airlines que salió del
aeropuerto internacional dulles en
washington y estrelló en el lado
sudoeste del pentágono sede del
departamento de defensa de eeuu desde
acá se planificó y se puso en marcha la
guerra contra el terrorismo que derivó
en la invasión a afganistán e irak entre
otras misiones militares el objetivo era
encontrar y hacer responsable a los que
llevaron a cabo los atentados
terroristas del 11 de septiembre del
la nueva doctrina de guerra del ex
presidente george w.bush comandante en
jefe en ese momento era hacer la guerra
de forma preventiva es decir atacar a
las personas y potenciales terroristas
en el mundo antes de que éstos atacaran
a eeuu
[Música]
para hablar de la guerra contra el
terrorismo y sus resultados estamos con
el profesor evan ellis profesor de la
escuela militar del ejército de eeuu
profesor evan ellis usted cree que eeuu
está más expuesto ataques terroristas de
lo que estaba hace 20 años cuando empezó
la guerra contra el terrorismo yo creo
que en balance sí por 30 son sus en
número uno es que los terroristas con
nuestro retiro de afganistán tienen más
espacio y tiempo para planificar
operaciones ella número dos obviamente
están más animados por ver el gobierno
de de la banda ahora de pensar en
ataques cuatro de los eeuu y también
algo que siempre ha existido eso sí en
otras partes del mundo los grupos
animados por atacar en blancos del
occidente y en mercados pero también hay
que reconocer que con el retiro de
nosotros nuestras fuerzas de afganistán
igual como irak también hay cosas menos
probables y también menos a fuerzas
expuesto de ser atacado en esta área y
en este sentido entonces yo creo que hay
un poco menos presión inmediato pero el
prólogo plazo sí me temo que estamos
yendo a un mundo más peligroso el
presidente yo bailé dijo que va a
revelar informes confidenciales de la
investigación del fbi ve que podemos
esperar de sus informes bueno no sé
exactamente los contenidos de estos
informes claro no me sorprendería si ese
nombre en el fútbol de ib3 un grupo en
rabia saudita o si siempre hemos
conocido que grupos apoyando los
wahabíes y también financiando el
terrorismo y en arabia saudita y también
en otras partes del mundo que hemos
controlado aliados de los estados unidos
pero por otro lado hay que reconocer que
hay parte de esto también tiene que ver
con la política de la administración
anterior de presidente de trump y tengo
confianza que a dónde apunta rodeado de
ese informe yo creo que esta
administración va a buscar quién está
culpable y en cualquier país que sea
como debería el americano promedio el
que está en tennessee en ohio recordar
esta guerra en afganistán se puede
considerar este retiro de forma de
emergencia de kabul como una fracaso en
esta guerra contra el terrorismo
yo creo que hay dos niveles en que
recordarlos hay de nivel operacional o
táctico y hay que reconocer que hay
muchas personas que han entregado en
buena facebook sus vidas en este caso se
parecieron a afganistán más justo más
seguro más democrático en apoyo de
nuestro propio seguridad no sólo
nuestros soldados fallecidos y los
debutantes sino también los halcones y
también tenemos hablar de los civiles
por ejemplo de las mujeres y los niños
que nada arriesgado mucho de conjuntarse
en maneras diferentes que anteriormente
en la sociedad afgana pero por otro lado
hay que reconocer mientras que haya
entrado estas personas también que para
nosotros esto fue un reconocimiento de
de sus límites en lo que tenemos lograr
y en intentar convertir un mundo
en democracia en nuestro propio imagen
tenemos que tomar el mundo como lo
encontramos sino como lo deseamos hacer
[Música]
la guerra contra el terrorismo logró uno
de sus principales objetivos en mayo de
2011 cuando acabó con la vida de osama
bin laden en pakistán eeuu continuó casi
diez años más en afganistán y tuvo que
retirarse de forma de emergencia de
kabul ciudad hoy controlada por los
talibanes
y como lo menciona nuestro corresponsal
en washington cristóbal vázquez es
entonces cuando empieza la guerra contra
el terrorismo
eeuu invadió afganistán para conseguir
la captura o la muerte de osama bin
laden objetivo que se cumplió casi diez
años después en 2011 una guerra que se
convirtió además en la más larga en la
que ha participado la unión americana y
que 20 años después muchos se preguntan
si valió la pena veamos más en el
siguiente informe que preparamos para
ustedes
en octubre de 2001 el gobierno de eeuu
con george w.bush a la cabeza anunció el
inicio de la guerra contra el terrorismo
que se libraría fuera de las fronteras
estadounidenses
ediciones de este mail en el conflicto
de gas natural fin y complementos pases
diarios en kilos deben acciones dejarme
los temores de más se les negó take the
long live at the throne pero
el
país
entero
días después una coalición internacional
liderada por washington invadió
afganistán para derrocar al grupo
talibán al que acusaba de proteger a
osama bin laden y a otros jefes de al
qaeda los talibanes que tomaron el poder
después de una ocupación soviética se
negaron a entregarlos el grupo huyó de
kabul hacia pakistán
en diciembre de ese mismo año la casa
blanca- publica este vídeo en el que
osama bin laden asume la autoridad de
los ataques del 11 de septiembre
[Música]
meses después bus también incluyó a irak
en su eje del mal y acusó a saddam
hussein de tener vínculos con al-qaeda y
armas de destrucción masiva
eeuu sin radio a irak y derrocó a
hussein pero el armamento nuclear nunca
fue hallado y se dio paso a un conflicto
entre las fuerzas iraquíes y los
insurgentes que devinieron con los años
en el autodenominado estado islámico el
14 al qaeda se desligó de ellos en un
comunicado en paralelo la cia lleva a
cabo una cacería de 10 años que según un
informe del senado estadounidense
utilizó actos de tortura como
ahogamiento simulado aislamiento extremo
y privación del sueño en guantánamo y
otros centros de detención para obtener
información que rindieron fruto en la
noche del primero al 2 de mayo de 2011
cuando dos helicópteros despegaron desde
afganistán hacia el norte de pakistán
con 23 integrantes de la unidad de
fuerzas especiales
desde la sala de crisis de la casa
blanca bajo la administración obama se
vivieron momentos de tensión que
quedarán para la historia en esta foto
es night like in recorte de tipos entre
the world ordinario state se les
contactó en una versión de bild usamos
vengan del iderbol cairo
además de bienes en mente
osama bin laden fue identificado con
pruebas de adn y software de
reconocimiento facial sus restos fueron
arrojados al mar sin dejar rastro para
evitar que se convirtiera en santuario
de extremistas
dos años después en 2013 el fundador del
grupo talibán mulá omar murió en un
hospital de karachi la otan finalizó su
misión en afganistán en diciembre de
2014 pero mantuvo 13.000 soldados para
apoyar los operativos antiterroristas
en 2015 el grupo talibán inicia una
serie de ataques con coches bomba y para
2020 bajo la administración de donald
trump firma un acuerdo de paz en doha
qatar en el que se acuerde retirar todas
las tropas extranjeras en 14 meses el 31
de agosto de 2021 si se mantiene el cese
de hostilidades en mayo de 2021 los
talibanes comienzan un operativo de
retoma que llega a su punto máximo para
el 15 de agosto cuando cae kabul miles
de personas se aglomeraron en el
aeropuerto de la capital afgana buscando
huir ante el temor de que el regreso del
talibán trajera consigo una aplicación
extrema de la sharía la ley islámica
haciendo retroceder los derechos ganados
en 20 años por niños y mujeres
especialmente aún así el presidente joe
biden completó y defendió su retirada
argumentando que la misión había sido
cumplida
y es que este hecho que partió en dos la
historia tiene muchas otras aristas una
más es la aviación comercial antes de
estos atentados no era necesario por
ejemplo quitarse el abrigo o los zapatos
para pasar por los controles del
aeropuerto veamos en el siguiente
informe que preparamos en la redacción
en bogotá como cambio el viajar en avión
las familias de los pasajeros de los
cuatro aviones secuestrados por al qaeda
para los atentados del 11 de septiembre
acordaron no demandar a las aerolíneas
era un mundo distinto sin protocolos que
permitieron a los extremistas ingresar
armas blancas a las aeronaves se
ajustaron los filtros de seguridad y no
se permitió ingresar con cuchillos o
tijeras en el equipaje de mano se
instalaron los equipos especiales para
revisar las maletas lo que alargó las
filas y tiempos de abordaje llegaron los
escáner 360° aumentaron las máquinas de
rayos x los detectores de armas y de
explosivos además se aumentaron los
precios para facturar el equipaje y se
implementaron otros cargos extra por
servicios y se hizo obligatorio pasar
por el escáner el 100% del equipaje de
bodega antes se hacía solo
aleatoriamente también se prohibió a las
personas que no fueran a viajar ingresar
a la sala de espera y se creó la
administración de seguridad de
transporte que obliga a las aerolíneas a
entregar información de cada pasajero el
concepto de seguridad en los aeropuertos
va mucho más allá de lo que pueda pasar
específicamente entre los límites de un
aeropuerto y precisamente el la meta de
todas las medidas y estándares que se
aplican es prevenir que es el presente
cualquier amenaza
en los aeropuertos incluso ser
aeropuertos adentro del avión las
puertas de cabina de los pilotos fueron
blindadas para hacer frente a las
pérdidas en vuelos que alcanzaron los 55
mil millones de dólares durante el 2001
varias aerolíneas comerciales se
fusionaron este año que estamos
recordando un box ataques terroristas 11
de septiembre
hemos implementado lo que se conoce como
el año de la cultura de seguridad en la
aviación el georges se quiere tico 8
tiene programas de cooperación técnica
para garantizar que los estados que no
cuenten con la capacidad para cumplir
con estos estándares internacionales
pues es lb en su capacidad e implementen
estos estándares internas mochis se
estima que las compañías aéreas
perdieron durante la pandemia de kobe
1921 mil millones de dólares menos de la
mitad que hace 20 años
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
especial de aquí américa gracias también
a nuestros invitados y nuestros
corresponsales ya todo el equipo
periodístico y de producción sigan más
con france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]
siempre que hay un líder